après demain vont arriver à genève les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
quatre grands à l'ordre du jour de la
réunion
le sort d'une ville dont dépend le sort
du monde berlin ce problème vous en avez
souvent entendu parler mais que
connaissez vous au juste de ces données
pour le savoir michel péricard s'est
livré pour cinq colonnes à la une à une
petite enquête à laquelle quelques-uns
d'entre vous ont bien voulu se prêter au
hasard d'une promenade nous avons
interrogé en effet quelques personnes
monsieur georges albert marchand de
fruits et légumes a besoin mademoiselle
monique jouanno poulos 22 ans rencontré
rue de la paix sans profession apparente
dans une très importante usine de
produits chimiques à boulogne
monsieur bouffard ouvrière monsieur but
aux directeurs de banques et enfin
couple d'amoureux désirant conserver
l'anonymat lui est agent dans un lycée à
paris ça doit être à peu près dans le
centre vous savez moi je chéris graphie
ouais position bien longtemps on se doit
de quoi dans des événements oui trouve
entre les deux allemagnes
quand la frontière
elle est évidemment malheureusement
depuis la guerre séparé en deux par les
par les occupations des différentes
armées et malheureusement cette
situation est tout en étant tout à fait
artificielle normalement devraient être
arrivés à 7 à s'effacer un jour est-ce
que berlin est toujours occupée
militairement
ah oui d'après moi oui pigeons non
laquelle
wes le froid a choisi berlin est
toujours occupée militairement par
l'écart n'est pas requis par les quatre
les quatre les quatre par les américains
et les russes et de vue des paniers avec
quatre ascensions c'est même un poil et
qui je crois est ce que le riz d'auxerre
passe par berlin alors là je ne sais pas
je crois que berlin est en dehors de la
zone
le fait
vieux monsieur n'ont soulevé la
politique moi ça il domine le parlement
wallon mignonne à la porte de
brandebourg je m'attendais pas non je ne
sais pas
le ya un double rideau de fer celui de
la frontière entre la république
orientale allemande est celui de la
république fédérale qui est plus à
l'ouest
d'une part et la zone la zone
d'occupation vers la étant coupée en
deux en deux zones différentes
et lui aussi coupé en deux
malheureusement parce rideau de fer
vous ne le voyez pas mais tout le
problème est là berlin est à 300 km à
l'intérieur de l'allemagne communiste
mais il est lui même coupé en deux et
pour vous le faire mieux comprendre
notre envoyé spécial george clooney va
vous amener avec lui dans ces deux
berlin avoue georges pensionnés
je voudrais essayer de vous faire
comprendre ce que c'est que cette
coupure de berlin en deux images in est
ce que ce serait par exemple si à paris
la gare montparnasse avait l'aspect de
cette gare lalanne albanov en plein
coeur de berlin avec des rails qui ne
viennent de nulle part et qui ne vont
plus nulle part ou bien que vous vouliez
téléphoner des champs elysées par
exemple à un ami qui habite rive gauche
et qu'il vous faille pour cela demandé
la communication pour orléans ou bien
encore qu'il y ait deux monnaies dans la
même ville et que ces deux monnaies
n'est pas la même valeur
voilà quelques-uns des paradoxes de
berlin
et en voici un autre ce monument ce
monument soviétique juste avant
d'arriver à la porte de brandebourg
du côté d'occidental dont il y a deux
soldats soviétiques qui montent la garde
et on pourrait presque dire qu'il n'y a
plus de soldats russes à berlin sinon
justement à berlin ouest
bon et bien revenons maintenant à la
porte de brandebourg est suivi le guide
ce sera moi aujourd'hui le guide dans
cette voiture du gouvernement militaire
français et suivent et surtout le manège
de cette jeune fille regardez bien ce
qu'elle fait vous comprendrez plus tard
la raison de ce geste quant à la raison
pour laquelle j'abandonne si
cavalièrement cette jeune fille et son
ami
c'est très seul tout le monde peut
passer à pied ou en voiture de l'ouest à
l'est le rideau de fer ici on peut le
traverser
légalement seulement cette voiture et
française une voiture des forces
d'occupation et à ce titre les policiers
n'ont pas le droit de la fouille et ou
de demander leurs papiers aux occupants
alors pour rester dans leur bon droit
les occupants français anglais ou
américains quand ils sont dans des
voitures officielles évite de faire
franchir la porte de brandebourg à des
allemands d'où cette manoeuvre vous
voyez de l'autre côté de la porte les
policiers populaire ne nous ont rien
demandé à cause de la plaque de la
voiture
il ne nous reste plus qu'à embarquer les
deux jeunes filles
voilà c'est fait en route en route pour
très bientôt
alors là regardez bien je crois que
c'est la première fois qu'un film sur
treptow est publiée à l'ouest
très tôt ce n'est pas seulement un
monument à la gloire des 20000 russes
morts pendant la bataille de berlin
c'est un véritable coup de poing dans le
visage ou dans le coeur de l'allemagne
entre les deux gigantesque drapeau vous
venez de voir qu'ils sont rouges qui
tente qui ont été taillé dans le marbre
de la chancellerie d'hitler vous allez
découvrir maintenant un panorama gigue
en effet près d'un kilomètre et qui
conduit au mausolée des héros il y à
sousse et pelouse
les corps de sept mille soldats russes
et le sens de treptow et bien c'est le
rappel brutal du passé les russes ont
voulu dire aux allemands souvenez vous
de ce que vous avez fait nous vous
empêcherons de recommencer autrement dit
et pour d'aussi bonnes raisons
politiques le contraire de la politique
occidentale qui elle pourrait se
traduire le passé est mort oubliant le
n'en parle on est maintenant à berlin
est toujours voici sur des ruines
voici l'avenir
les allemands de l'est le régime
communiste a construit à sa manière
du neuf
[Musique]
c'est l'entrée de la stalle inhalé
l'orgueil du berlin communiste
c'est grand c'est large cet imposant
c'est très bourgeois
mais enfin cela existe et cela de la lui
les m'abuse les magasins sont
naturellement ici ce qu'on fait de mieux
à berlin est
[Musique]
et puis sans transition voici
l'antithèse la réplique occidental le
court furent steendam ce sont les champs
elysées de berlin ouest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les magasins des vitrines sont à la
pointe du modernisme
il s'agit bien entendu de montrer aux
autres de l'autre côté que la
civilisation occidentale est
incomparable oui que rien ne peut lui
être égalée
donc berlin le grand berlin vous en avez
déjà une première vision c'est une ville
une seule ville mais et les couper en
deux et elle est en principe administré
par quatre généraux en fait les quatre
généraux ne se voit plus guère sinon
peut-être ici h pentaho la prison des
criminels de guerre ou les trois
derniers grands chefs du nazisme
rudolph hess père et val-d'or von
schirach attendent une éventuelle grâce
et qu'ils affichaient à la relève de la
garde
les américains s'en vont ce sont les
russes qui ce mois ci les remplacent
autrefois ce n'est pas acheter pendant
que se rencontrer les généraux mais ici
à la commande à tour à interallié
c'était le vrai gouvernement du grand
berlin et puis les russes un beau jour
ont claqué la porte il ne reste plus que
trois drapeaux pour quatre mâts 3
uniforme et une place vip
ces images déjà vous prouve la présence
française à berlin mais voici maintenant
le quartier général français dans la
partie nord ouest de berlin à tes gars
c'est c'était l'entrée de la caserne
napoléon et si vous doutiez encore qu'il
y est une véritable colonie française en
plein coeur de l'allemagne orientale et
bien regardez et écoutez
alors venez tous les matins chercher vos
journaux ici oui comme d'habitude
dites moi comment est ce que vous êtes
de france et a permis aux trois mille
3000 soldats et qu'est ce que c'est
comme unité que le 46e pays bataillon
d'infanterie le 11e chasseur vous vous
êtes des chasseurs des cavaliers bon et
je voudrais savoir un peu en quoi
d'abord qui êtes vous gautier paulin
xavi de chantilly dans l'oise
je suis peintre en bâtiment battant
vadim on veut vous êtes chassèrent
cavaliers
comment est ce que vous appelez curtis
affaires et d'où venez-vous chalet sans
doute
ah bon vous êtes presque un montagnard
que les deux ans ans et qu'est ce que
fait comme métier
ses 3000 français
ils ont créé une véritable petite ville
à l'intérieur de la grande cité
et puis de plus en plein centre sur le
kurfürstendamm que vous avez déjà vu
tout à l'heure une sorte de havre de
point de rencontre c'est la maison de
france seulement allé à berlin pour y
rencontrer des français c'est
insuffisant alors je suis allé pour vous
bavarder avec un ouvrier allemand dans
un petit garage tout près de ces grands
bâtiments
ces grands bâtiments de siemens lusine
la plus importante de berlin quant à
l'ouvrier le voici
eh bien d'abord qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
par cette fois tu suis mécano
français comme ça avant j'étais
prisonnier en france touraine un sourire
fémur à la flèche
apprenant qu'en même temps ça fait
presque deux ans vous êtes berlinois ou
bien des espoirs nos sites originaux
très lié au plaisir oui monsieur
réfugiés ici à pearl away dans du déjà
21 ah bon mais est-ce que vous avez de
la famille de l'autre côté
oui entendu avec sa famille à berlin
voilà typiquement le berlinois plastique
à écouter jouer savoir ce n'est pas ce
que vous pensez un peu d'astuce y ont
tué les ce qu'ils avaient l'impression
que à berlin-ouest ya un malaise
que vous dire qu'il ya des gens qu'ils
ont fait rien du genre aussi qu'il
espérait repartir assez les stocks en
révision d'un éventuel brennus en berne
a justement été acquis par 10 voix
pouvoir faire le poids face à vermeer
vous avez faire que quelque chose se
passe
c'est à dire les choses tournaient mal
voir que c'est à dire que les alliés
[ __ ] c'est à dire que les russes rue
et berlin
est ce que vous croyez que c'est fatal
ou bien est ce qu'on les avis vont
pouvoir l'empêcher
pour nous ça ça j'avais je pense oui
vous me parlez de votre frère keith
autre côté est ce que sa famille est
orienté politiquement différemment tout
mon frère lui ont fait beaucoup de bruit
je crains que vous entendez pas non plus
pas dire que nous sommes divisés parce
que nous les vieux nous sommes déjà
mousson du lala cela c'est de la
politique
mais la jeunesse qui s'activent toujours
en dur intérieur question quotidien
politique surtout ils sont de plus
l'entretien sont beaucoup plus attiré
son groupe les activés par an à la
propagande
oui c'est ça enfin il ya toute l'europe
du nord je dirais même que si tu m'as
peu près même la méthode est propre à
peu près c
la vie d'abord la promesse et puis vous
avez
écoutez comment est ce que vous aimez
comment sortir cette affaire là presque
à berlin on pense que la conférence de
genève où une autre conférence pour
ramener quelque chose du square
justement nous espérons qu'elle a
l'apparence et je n'ai remis les choses
en coin à libérer de l'apport dû nous
rendre la vie tranquille comme nous
avons griffes d'un temps voilà vous en
savez maintenant à peu près autant que
moi sur berlin c'est une ville étrange
monstrueuse même d'accord mais pourtant
je vous assure captivante avec toutes
ces ruines qui voisinent avec les
immeubles les plus modernes
restait pour conclure ce reportage à
aller voir le champion des libertés
berlinoise vie libre en l'homme fort de
berlin ouest et dont on reparlera sans
doute quelques jours à un poste plus
élevé que celui de premier magistrat de
berlin il m'a reçu à l'hôtel de ville de
chenôve père et voici ce que je vais
demander monsieur le bourgmestre je
voudrais savoir quels sont les principes
absolus que vous entendez défendre en
cas de mouvements de la conférence
maintenant quels sont les points sur
lesquels vous ne voulez pas céder et
scripts sont extrèmement bas
d'abord mahdi vibrante il faut que je la
liberté politique et individuelles
soient garantis mieux qu'avec des
papiers officiels
il faut que nous puissions informer nos
compatriotes de l'est et c'est la raison
de ce journal lumineux que nous avons
installé à la limite des secteurs
occident et puis problème des réfugiés
il faut que nous puissions et ceux
d'entre eux qui frappent à notre porte
c'est à dire en somme les deux mille
personnes qui chaque semaine parviennent
à berlin ouest
monsieur leur mettre une dernière
question vous avez ici un insigne à la
boutonnière
c'est assez ja est ce que vous pouvez me
dire ce que c'est bien cet insigne c'est
une reproduction de la porte de
brandebourg un symbole en quelque sorte
et tous les allemands de l'ouest ont
tenu à l'arborer à leurs vestons on en a
vendu en quelques semaines une quinzaine
de millions et naturellement il ne
faudrait pas sa visée de se promener de
l'autre côté de la porte de brandebourg
avec 7 à 6,1 à la boutonnière et le
slogan qui est attaché à ce symbole
c'est ouvrait la porte
[Musique]